so excited about today's sponsor soul
guard a premium and sustainable travel
gear company that's near and dear to the
star talk family this one is special
people come on see for yourself that's
mars by the way for a limited time soul
guard and star talk have teamed up to
provide you with limited edition out of
this world travel gear now check out
this moon one right here it's even got
montez aponinus on it and yes neil made
sure of it now the suitcase is called
the carry-on closet because it has a
patented built-in closet system that
looks like it was invented by jedi's and
makes packing and unpacking a thing of
the past now this is a limited edition
collection but it not only includes
suitcases featuring the amazing surface
textures of the moon
and mars there's also a backpack and a
watch and get this they're all made with
ocean-bound plastic that's right with
sawguard products every order saves 229
plastic bottles from the ocean now we're
over the moon excited about this
collaboration and you should be too
learn more at soulguard.co
star talk or visit the link in the video
description this is a limited edition
collaboration when they're gone they're
gone so make sure you use the discount
code star talk at checkout for an
exclusive discount almost as exclusive
as going to space with the billionaire
[Music]
chuck we're back yes
do you like these these explainers of
course i uh
be one
because neil splaining has always been
good for
that's a good thing okay for me okay you
know uh all other explainings are not
good man
mansplaining ain't good you know what i
mean blacks playing white splaining
ain't good
but
it works that's a whole other thing yeah
thank you for that those words of
encouragement so i'll just continue look
cool and what do you got so i got today
we've all heard of gravity assists for
spacecraft yes that's uh that was in on
space jam right it's a gravity assault
oh that was oh that's it people i just
retired
it's over
because that was the worst i've ever
done in my life
jesus
so a gravity assist the way people
typically think about it is you
you send out a spacecraft and you want
it to give it more speed than it
currently has right and so you find some
planet that it sort of
falls towards and of course it'll speed
up as it does that right and we think of
it as kind of a slingshot
where it fl obviously it falls not
towards it but towards the side of it
yes otherwise it's not a gravity assist
it's a gravity crash
so you want it to sort of swing by
and it picks up speed in so doing and it
flings out the other side and if you if
you angle it right and position it right
you could head towards your next
destination and as a result you can have
multiple destinations in the same voyage
so famously
voyager one and two this is back in the
1970s when it was launched they had
trajectories
that well let me say that differently
the solar system's planets
were configured in such a way that it
could get multiple planetary
assists right multiple gravitational
assists and
by the time it was done it had so many
gravitational assists it had enough
energy to leave the solar system
entirely wow and you could end up doing
that without using a very big rocket to
begin with
right so you're basically exploiting the
gravitational attraction of planets
rather than
for your speed rather than spending
money on fuel so it's the poor man's way
to get out
it's basically cosmic drafting drafting
i like that cosmic drafting it's just
like why should i paddle
let this sucker pedal for me
think about this
as you approach a planet and its gravity
attracts you
everyone has said and it believes and
thinks
that it pulls you in and then flings you
out the other side but wait a minute
yeah just like uh just like uh there
used to be for me with women at a
nightclub was it how that worked for you
there was an attraction
[Music]
[Laughter]
so the problem with thinking of it that
way
is the same gravity that's pulling you
in
is also preventing you from leaving
right
okay so you'll speed up
as you fall in but now as you try to
escape the gravity's saying no i'm
pulling you back right
so it turns out if you look at the pure
gravity picture
it is exactly symmetric to the planet
right
okay the planet pulls you in you gain
speed
you have maximum speed right when you're
passing the planet now you want to exit
the planet the planet starts pulling you
back right over your timing i try to get
out
this you your speed falling in and your
speed going back is an exact
mirror image of your motion
okay so then the question is how do i
end up getting all this damn speed
where are the slingshot effects okay
this is something that's hardly ever
explained and that's why we have these
explainer videos cool
so here's the answer it turns out
if you approach a planet from behind
okay okay there it is orbiting the sun
right and you approach it from behind in
its orbit right
not only will the gravity pull you in
[Music]
but you will gain speed just to catch up
with the planet in its orbit
that makes sense yes
right how are we gonna catch up how are
you gonna hit the planet come near the
planet unless you have the planet's
orbital speed right the planet's orbital
speed has nothing to do
with the planet with the planet's
gravity correct
okay so even though the gravity is
symmetric all the speed and energy you
gain falling in the planet takes back
away from you that's symmetric right but
the speed you get
from catching up with the planet in the
orbit is not symmetric raw look at that
okay
and so what actually happened is
you
were tugging on the planet
okay
as the planet was moving and you were
speeding up because of this but what it
means is you stole some of the planet's
orbital energy to do this wow they don't
tell you about that that's no they don't
so you basically you approach the planet
from behind
and you just like don't make a ghetto
mugging out of this yo
give me some of that speed
don't turn around don't look at my face
just give me the speed
nobody needs to get hurt
and then you take it and you keep going
and you've got the thing and it doesn't
and it doesn't have it and you have it
so this these are
this is the art of the of the slingshot
dude that is that's pretty amazing that
makes sense yeah you can slingshot off
of anything we've had planets
orbit the sun launched from earth and
then slingshot around earth twice
right wow okay on two can now it takes
longer right it's that's if you're not
in a hurry you do this you and it use
earth to slingshot you could slingshot
off the moon you slingshot off of mars
okay it doesn't matter what planet you
want to slingshot from right in the case
of voyager
a voyager one i think it's slung shot
what's past tense sub two slingshot it's
slung shotted sling yeah yeah
slang shot slang shots
it was slang shot anyway it's it's slang
[ __ ] off of off of jupiter right and so
people think well jupiter big gravity
will get a huge speed it's only getting
jupiter's orbital speed doesn't make
that clear look at that that's and
jupiter is traveling slower than planets
that orbit closer in so the
gravitational pull cancels out but the
orbital speed is what's left over and
that's what you ended up stealing in
order to get the speed to go and if you
want an inverse mugging
which no one will actually want to do in
space right if you you can fall towards
the planet right
opposite the direction it's traveling
oh wow okay
and if you do that
then you have sped up the planet it eats
some of your
or your your uh
trajectory's energy and you'll come out
the other side moving slower than you
did before oh so you could actually use
it as a break as a break that's correct
oh wow okay this is that's fascinating
stuff yeah if you want if you need it to
break in space that's a way and it takes
a long time to like line up and make it
all happen so there you have it wow look
at that cosmic drafting and space
breaking that's amazing
and so the more the more times you do
this the more energy you have more
speed you accumulate and that's how we
leave the solar system
cool
yeah and you might ask but you didn't uh
if you if you draft if you if you
slingshot off of mars like 20 times
like
what happens to the mars orbit itself if
you're taking away its energy you
probably haven't asked that no okay um i
don't make it because you don't care i
was going to say
you know i'm not worried about mars
i think mars is going to be okay but
anyway what does happen let's say if
over over over over over i mean you're
you're basically siphoning it off a tiny
little bit of energy siphoning off of
tiny little bit of energy so
okay so here's the thing uh
you know maybe in a trillion years if
you did this every day it would matter
but the mass of these objects relative
to the mass of our measly probes okay
that ratio is so huge
that it's like a gnat flying full speed
ahead into an elephant
the elephant doesn't say
you know watch out
quit your shovel this the the mass
difference is so huge that it's not
relevant
it's not important in what's going on in
the solar system but in addition take
earth for example in any given day
we plow through
100 tons of meteors every single day wow
tons so this stuff fallen and and and
this stuff so it's
don't worry about it we have other
things we should be worrying about like
climate change
yes tell me about it
you know so if you were worried about oh
my gosh what how about mars where about
your own damn planet how about that
i'm all about that speaking of mars you
said
worry about your own planet don't worry
about mars and so
i got both of them in one
i got a mars bag from the out of this
world uh collection from soul guard
right and check this out every single
suitcase that they make pulls about 229
bottles of plastic out of the
environment so really yes so here we are
with mars and we worried about our own
planet at the same time boom
wait wait so you're saying i should
drink more plastic bottles no you can
make more of those that luggage no
take away no no
i'm saying for the idiots that drink
plastic bottles this is part of the
solution
and for the smart people who want to buy
this and help that's what they should do
okay so so it's not only gets the
bottles out uh if you like the universe
if you love the universe
you got one that looks like mars yep
that's right that's very cool 12 million
plastic bottles pulled in 2021 right
see that's what we're doing here wait
chuck do i recognize valus marineris on
that
really don't pretend like i'm like
because here's what i'm saying do you
no it looks like a high resolution image
of martian surface it's not just like
red
all right not pretending to be mars it
is mars it's got very good detail on the
surface that's so highly recognizable if
you're mars fluent which apparently
you're not no okay i don't speak martian
i'm sorry
dallas marineris is basically the mars
valley and it's a huge canyon way bigger
than the grand canyon here on earth okay
and it's a very striking
scar
in the martian surface clearly mars has
had a whole lot of activity long ago
shaping and forming and and reshaping
its surface and that's one other bits of
evidence of it so that that that adds to
the authenticity of what you got in your
hands there very cool i'm just going to
let you talk while i sit here and play
black vanna white
is that how that goes
but i need a vowel though
yeah i got a i got a few of them right
here oh yeah there you go i i can i can
tell you this that there's nothing more
boring than people's luggage
so think about it yeah absolutely
by the way speaking of that so now
there's a piece of luggage that like
that's good i want one there's some
exciting looks by the way the cool thing
about this not only is it like it's mars
right here which means that when it
can't argue with mars when it comes down
the chute right
okay
mars down the conveyor belt mars is
coming down the conveyor belt you'll be
able to recognize yours and as a matter
of fact you can turn to somebody and go
get your eyes to mars
but don't take my luggage while you do
okay very cool all right
they're working on good stuff gotta love
this girl guard all right
all right chuck so that's all we have
intent that was great i love it so now
you know and i never thought to
analogize
a gravity assist with a mugging
i'm glad i could be of service yeah
thank you chuck always always
with those socially enlightened
analogies that you give us here on star
talk so that's yet another star talk
explainer as always
[Music]
you